imagine a world millions of years in the
future where evolution has written a new
chapter in the story of life
that was the tagline of the future is
wild a mini series that aired in the
early 2000s exploring the speculative
life forms of the far future and it was
amazing
i think this show left an impact on a
lot of people myself included
i love this series and i think my
interest in it helped set me on the path
which eventually led to me making this
channel the special effects are of
course a little dated by today's
standards but the world is fantastically
detailed and an impressive team of real
scientists came up with the creatures
that inhabit it and while some of the
predictions are pretty out there people
forget the future is wild never set out
to flawlessly predict future life forms
but to get people excited about biology
and earth science
and i think these creatures definitely
deserve a nostalgic second look even if
you've never heard of them before
so for this extra long entry into the
archive we'll be exploring this
hypothetical future having fun
incorporating contemporary scientific
discoveries that might provide new
insight into these speculative life
forms and just appreciating the richness
of the world the series created so
prepare to jump forward several million
years to the first era of the future is
wild
the future is wild is divided into three
eras set 5 million 100 million and 200
million years into the future
our journey begins in the 5 million year
era when earth is locked in an ice age
humans aren't present in this narrative
having either left the planet or long
since died out
we'd know this frozen wasteland as
northern france but it's now
unrecognizable buried under sheets of
ice over half a mile or one kilometer
thick
and stalking this icy tundra is the
first life form of the future
this is a snow stalker a saber-tooth
predator searching desperately for a
meal
the scientists imagine snow stalkers are
the descendants of wolverines which have
moved from predator to apex predator
thanks to an available niche
essentially a bigger and heavier version
of their ancestors with the addition of
protruding saber teeth to take down
large prey the snow stalker is a
grounded speculative life form and one
of my favorites when i was younger
this snow stalker has journeyed all the
way from the coast in search of food and
it might have found some in the form of
gannett whales despite their size these
blubbery beach dwellers are actually
aquatic birds and have come ashore to
lay their eggs their ancestor is the
modern gannet a bird that can already
dive underwater and swim with its wings
the concept of a gannet transitioning to
a dolphin-sized animal in just 5 million
years is in some ways surprising it
might make more sense for example to
expect that already aquatic animals like
sea lions and penguins would be the ones
to evolve into a niche left by whales
and their relatives but we now know
better than ever from the fossil record
that whales themselves evolved from a
rodent-like animal into a large
seafaring one remarkably quickly so
gannit whales though unexpected aren't
impossible and while a single gannet
whale would be a mighty feast for a
snowstalker this group is just too large
to be worth the trouble
further inland however another potential
source of food is moving across the
plains on the horizon a herd of shag
rats log their way through the snow
these thick coated creatures are the
descendants of alpine marmets although
the shag rats are over three times
larger than their rodent ancestors
and while shag rats look a bit like musk
oxen they aren't much bigger than sheep
so 5 million years is plenty of time for
such a life form to emerge upon the
tundra yet shag rats aren't big enough
to deter predator like a snow stalker
all it takes is for one of them to fall
behind the herd and the weary snow
stalker can at last get its meal
yet this meal won't just feed one mouth
this particular snowstalker is a mother
and is bringing back food for her two
cubs it's a moment that has always stuck
out to me as it shows us that even in
the most competitive ecosystems parental
instincts haven't changed
but other ecosystems are even more
barren the scientists imagine that to
the south tectonic and temperature
shifts have transformed the
mediterranean sea into vast salt flats
dashing along this harsh expanse is a
cryptile these lizards are some of the
only creatures that can endure this arid
desert thanks to their clever method of
getting moisture
near pools of brine enormous swarms of
brine flies reproduce and take to the
air these engorged flies are an
excellent source of food and water for
anything that can catch them and the
kryptile is an expert fly trapper the
lizard rushes through the huge swarm
using its neck frill as a fishing net
and licking the trap flies off the net
as it runs
it's an extreme concept for a life form
but a believable one the kryptile like a
lot of the best life forms in the future
is wild takes numerous unique traits
from modern animals such as frilled
lizards and salt lake ground dragons and
combines them into a new yet still
plausible life form
rising out of the salt the mediterranean
islands are now mountains of eroded
limestone rock for cryptiles they make
an ideal egg-laying location
deep fissures in the rock called grikes
mark the island's surface and some of
these miniature canyons are narrow
enough that they are inaccessible to
most predators but near the larger
grikes a kryptile needs to be on its
guard for there is a predator here a
stealthy griken that takes advantage of
the natural cover the grikes provide the
griken's closest ancestor is the pine
martin a small predator that today
navigates the branches of trees instead
of narrow canyons but five million years
is a reasonable stretch of time for a
pine marten to become a deadly graiken
efficient as grikens are however the
kryptile has the advantage of speed
but the kryptile isn't the preferred
prey of the griecans
instead the delicate looking pigs known
as scrofas are their primary food source
at a glance it's easy to tell the
scrofas are the descendants of wild wars
but with one distinct change scrofa leg
bones have become elongated with the
animals now walking on the tips of their
toes it's an adaptation we've documented
elsewhere in nature this hoof design
mirrors those of clip springer antelopes
which have similar ballet shoe-like
hooves to move on rocky outcroppings
so considering the scrofa's environment
their strange hoof structure holds up to
scientific scrutiny with pigs this
athletic the grikens have their work cut
out for them in trying to catch one
further south is one of the regions i
remember most distinctly from my
childhood huge grassy plains stretch
across the south american landscape
where the amazon rainforest stood before
the ice age and upon this amazon prairie
a strange troupe of ground-dwelling
monkeys called babukaris move through
the tall grass the babukaris are fairly
intelligent weaving strange basket-like
traps and placing them in shallow lakes
to catch small fish which are their
primary food source while this level of
tool use in a primate might seem
surprising we now have even more
documentation than when this documentary
first aired of primates using tools to
get to their food but the monkey the
babokari are theoretically evolved from
the red-faced bukhari aren't among those
that have been documented using basic
tools
capuchin monkeys might be the more
expected ancestor to the plane's
dwelling babukari as they're already
transitioning in the present day to a
less arboreal lifestyle and have used
stones to break open food
but no matter their ancestor the
babookari's existence on the plains is
imagined to be quite perilous for the
troop is always in danger of being eaten
by the mighty kara killers enormous
birds that patrol the grasslands and
groups like the babookari the care
killer's ancestor is a bit surprising as
they're imagined to have evolved from
small falcons in just 5 million years
time a larger modern bird like the
red-legged sirima whose ancestors the
terror birds or the real world
inspiration of the cara killer are
another potential starting point for
these giants
but in either case care killers for all
their strength can't do much to a
creature like a rattleback these
reptile-like armored omnivores are
imagined to have too thick a shell for
care killers to break through
their armor is actually derived from
hair which has become matted infused
into hard scales this is because the
rattleback isn't a reptile at all but a
mammal imagined to have evolved from a
forest-dwelling rodent species they were
another one of my favorites from this
era although admittedly a rodent
transitioning into a reptile-like
creature that can move its scales
independently in just 5 million years
would be quite the transformation
but a relative of the rattleback that is
closer to its mammalian ancestor dwells
in the bleak desert of central north
america in this ice age desert the north
american rattleback braves the intense
cold this particular rattleback is a
mother traveling with her baby and they
are facing the intense winds of a
sandstorm luckily their spines aren't
just adapted to deter predators but also
to protect themselves from the
unforgiving environment these creatures
are closer to what one might expect to
emerge in this evolutionary time frame
to find food the rattlebacks dig
underground for tubers but this mother
is unknowingly disturbing the burrow of
a highly unusual subterranean lifeform
this tiny creature is a [ __ ] and
although it might not look like it the
[ __ ] is a bird
according to the documentary the [ __ ]
evolved from quails near flightless
birds that transition to an underground
lifestyle the [ __ ] are another creature
that seems unusually specialized for
just 5 million years of transition
although we do have documentation of
other birds like bee eaters digging
burrows in which to lay their eggs but
the [ __ ] live almost their entire lives
in their tunnels and only come out under
cover of darkness peculiar as they are
i've always found these tunneling birds
strangely adorable
far less adorable are the creatures that
swoop overhead
with wingspans of four feet or 1 meter
these predators called death cleaners
look like giant predatory birds but
these are actually bats which have
evolved to take the spot of apex
predators in the north american skies
it would take a very special extinction
event for bats to out-compete large
north american birds of prey like eagles
and condors but certain modern species
of bats like flying foxes have already
reached similar sizes so from a
biomechanical perspective given the
right opportunity creatures like the
death cleaners could indeed take flight
the documentary then jumps to my
personal favorite era of 100 million
years into the future beginning in the
coastal swamps this is a version of
earth where hot and humid climate
conditions have led to a period of
tremendous biodiversity and no species
is more emblematic of this era of
abundance than the toraton
these lumbering giants are huge
described as being the largest land
animals ever exceeding the weight of
even the biggest dinosaur so it's
surprising that the ancestor of these
creatures is the species of tortoise
tortoises might not be the most expected
life form to break the size record
especially since we now have better
research suggesting that large dinosaurs
like sauropods could only get so large
thanks to their starting advantage of
lightweight bone construction
still i've always loved the concept of
giant tortoises and other aspects of the
toraton like legs that have shifted
under their body in their swampy
environment having a tremendous amount
of available plant matter make a lot of
sense considering their size
near the feet of the tortuns dwell a
family of swampus these excellently
named creatures are the descendants of
octopuses and remarkably they can move
on land
strange as that might sound we now have
more documentation than ever of
octopuses moving on the land in a
limited capacity using their tentacles
to haul themselves along the swampus
takes this concept further by being able
to breathe above water to some extent
sort of like the strange mud skippers of
today
and like the mud skipper the swampus
spends part of their time in the water
and aren't true land dwelling
cephalopods
those will come later
for now every time the swampus returns
to the water it has to be on high alert
for there is an apex predator here in
the murky depths that can feed on the
swampus this is a lurk fish a descendant
of the catfish that can sense the
swampus's movement thanks to a weak
electric field the lurkfish generates
but this terror of the wetland has
another use for electricity releasing a
powerful shock the lurkfish stuns the
swampus and swallows its meal in a
single gulp while this menacing life
form might seem far-fetched many modern
catfish hunt in a manner that is
surprisingly similar certain breeds of
catfish can produce a small shock thanks
to specialized mussels on their back
which the catfish uses to stun its prey
just like a lurk fish
but it's not just the swamps of this era
that the documentary imagines are much
changed higher global temperatures have
caused tremendous sea level rise with
many lowland regions now flooded
these vast shallow seas stretch across
the globe and are home to remarkable new
life forms this is an ocean phantom
always one of my favorites this complex
looking creature is a unique type of
siphonophore like modern siphonophores
the ocean phantom is actually composed
of numerous different life forms some of
which act as sails to help it navigate
these seas others of which help keep the
lifeform afloat and finally some which
trail below the colony to help it catch
food the idea of a life-form using
biological sails might sound a little
out there but some modern siphonophores
and their relatives have already evolved
something similar so while the ocean
phantom is certainly an unusual life
form frankly so are most modern
siphonophores
under the water's surface small
creatures swim in the shallow current at
a glance these creatures look like fish
but the scientists imagine they're
actually a descendant of the sea slug or
nudibranch
these are reef gliders and they play a
vital role in pollinating the red algae
that grows here free-swimming sea slugs
might have once seemed far-fetched but
the recently filmed cephalo feige is a
nudibranch that has evolved to spend its
entire life swimming in the ocean
current so the concept of a fish-like
sea slug such as the reef glider isn't
so unlikely after all
but the reef gliders are in danger here
in the open ocean for the ocean phantom
is a hunter and is quite adept at
snatching up reef gliders and using them
to feed the colony but feeding on reef
gliders is a dangerous gambit for while
young reef gliders are small adults are
large enough to pose a serious threat to
the soft ocean phantom
yet in cases where the colony is menaced
by an adult reef glider the ocean
phantom has one last form of protection
it has its own personal defense team in
the form of spindle troopers
huge sea spiders that live in chambers
of the phantom rush to defend their home
they attack the adult reef glider until
it backs off
the highly complex symbiosis between the
spindle troopers and the ocean phantoms
have modern parallels as the documentary
points out bodyguards aren't unheard of
in nature the trapezoid crab for example
lives among coral and protects its home
from coral-eating starfish with its
sharp pinchers
the ocean phantoms take this a step
further however by also providing their
spindle troopers with sustenance
produced from red algae that grows on
the ocean phantom's back truly these
siphonophores are almost like miniature
cities floating on the vast shallow seas
not all regions of this high temperature
earth are underwater however a vast
rainforest can be found upon a rather
unexpected continent we'd know this land
mass as antarctica but it has changed
much from our era becoming warmer and
warmer as tectonic plate shifts cause
the landmass to move upwards now near
the equator this green antarctica has
given rise to startling adaptations
birds are the main inhabitants of this
region as they were some of the few
animals able to migrate to this island
continent over the millennia but this
particular species the spitfire bird has
a defense unlike any we'd recognize when
threatened the spitfire bird sprays a
hot noxious fluid from its nose while
we've never seen such a defense evolve
in a bird from our time the bombardier
beetle can produce a burning acid-like
substance that can repel almost any
predator
the spitfire bird might just be the most
impressive bird species of the green
antarctic
on the nearby peaks of the great plateau
however another remarkable species is
waiting the mountain range where it
dwells was formed by the tectonic plates
of australia in southeastern asia
colliding a crash that would likely
result in peaks even higher than the
himalayas of today
and soaring over these peaks is a great
blue wind runner this giant bird
possesses a wingspan of almost 10 feet
or 3 meters and upon closer inspection
it actually has four wings not just two
to help it maintain altitude at the time
of the future's wild's production the
concept of a bird with four wings was
just speculation after its release
however a specimen of the microraptor
genus of dinosaur was discovered to have
four wings just like the windrunner
while the microraptor is of course a
life form from earth's past instead of
its future this discovery shows that
such a body plan was at some point
successful
while the windrunners are majestic a
much less appealing species lurks in the
gloom of the great plateau's caves these
are silver spiders massive arachnids
that have collected huge piles of grass
seeds but silver spiders are carnivores
the seeds aren't for them therefore a
small shy species of rodent the
amusingly named poggle while the
hamster-like poggles themselves are cute
their role in this ecosystem gave me
more existential dread during my
childhood than pretty much anything the
documentary imagines that poggles are
unsettlingly the very last of all mammal
species on earth and while the silver
spiders allow them to eat their fill of
seeds this is because the spiders are
farming the poggles
on occasion the spiders will attack one
poggle and drag it off to be eaten it's
a terrifying fate for the last mammal
and one i'm sure caused nightmares
across the globe
thankfully it's one of the less likely
hypotheticals mammals are highly
adaptable already having survived one
mass extinction and aren't likely to be
out-competed so thoroughly in all parts
of the globe that they go completely
extinct even in a hundred million years
but a world without mammals is an
interesting concept to explore as a
hypothetical which is part of the idea
behind the future is wild anyway
and 200 million years into the future
we've at last reached the final era of
the futures wild which scientists
imagine is home to the most
unrecognizable life forms of all this
version of planet earth now features a
single super continent and a single
global ocean much like the bygone era of
pangaea this is indeed where tectonic
plates are likely headed and the result
would be some truly extreme environments
on the edge of the coast what seem like
birds are flapping in the sky
but upon closer inspection these aren't
birds at all but aerial fish which the
documentary amusingly calls flesh
the flesh are an icon of the franchise
in a way and are meant to have evolved
from the gliding flying fish of today
in 200 million years such a life-form
evolving more efficient flight in
lung-like organs isn't so improbable a
hypothetical after all
and the air is one of the safer places
to be for in the waters of the global
ocean sharks are still patrolling this
bioluminescent species is a sharkopath
another entertaining name sharks
surviving this far into the future with
essentially the same body plan actually
makes complete sense as they've been
stalking our oceans for at least 400
million years with very few changes but
the introduction of bioluminescent
signals show the sharkopaths have become
coordinated pack hunters using their
flashes to keep track of each other
during a hunt
while the sharkopaths are deadly however
they aren't the largest lifeforms in the
global ocean
that distinction goes to the colossal
rainbow squid these highly intelligent
lifeforms are another one of my
childhood favorites due to their ability
to change color to ward off predators
displays like this are also present in
the cephalopods of today thanks to the
power of chromatophores
these are pigment-filled sacs in the
skin that can create remarkably complex
colors and patterns in response to
signals from the animal's brain but the
rainbow squid's chromatophores are
imagined to be on another level able to
render the creature virtually invisible
by matching the color of the water or by
lighting up the rainbow squid in a
dazzling display to others of their kind
a squid offshoot one day conquering the
sea is one thing but on land the
future's wild has one last surprise this
perpetually damp rainforest is located
on the northern portion of the era's
supercontinent and lumbering through the
forest is a 16 foot or 5 meter tall
squid
this is a mega squid one of the most
famous and debated life forms of the
future is wild like the swampus it's a
cethlopod that has traded the sea for
the land but unlike the swampus it is
now fully terrestrial
even in 200 million years a squid
becoming an elephant-sized land dweller
without a rigid skeleton seems
improbable but the documentary claims
the squid supports itself using a
network of circular and vertical muscles
that act as a pseudoskeleton and
according to calculations done by
mcneill alexander a late british
biomechanist who worked on the project
the math actually checks out in favor of
the megasquid so the mega squid while
extremely speculative might not be
completely impossible after all which is
a preferable outcome because the concept
of a giant forest dwelling squid is
amazing
and in the branches above the mega squid
the final creature of the future is wild
is waiting this is a squibbon another
type of terrestrial squid that spends
its life swinging from the branches of
the forest canopy and if that isn't
strange enough the documentary imagines
that navigating the three-dimensional
forest has made these creatures highly
intelligent indeed this 200 million year
journey ends with a stirring promise of
human-like intelligence re-emerging
through the squibbon it's a speculative
concept that is certainly unusual but
strangely compelling
while humans are gone forever in this
future the implication that a new
civilization of intelligent squids will
replace us is perhaps strangely
comforting
honestly i could have explored this
world forever but while there wasn't
enough time to cover every single life
form i hope i've shown why the future is
wild was something really special there
wasn't anything like it on tv at the
time and there hasn't really been
anything quite like it since hearing top
scientists get excited about the
creatures they've invented was just so
wholesome and i hope they know how much
the world they created meant to people i
hear there have been plans to revive the
show that have never quite materialized
and i think that's a shame i feel like a
modern remake or sequel with better
effects and even more science would be
really successful in the age of the
internet maybe one day we'll get more of
the future as wild but in the meantime
we have the incredible original which
has stood the test of time
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video
you